سته اشهر من عمر حكومه السوداني التي جاءت
بعد مخاض عسير تمثل بصدام مسلح وانقسام
حاد داخل البيت الشيعي فتره تتلخص بمجموعه
من النجاحات والوعود التي لم تتحقق على
المستوى السياسي
والاقتصادي والخدمي
سياسيا يحسب للسوداني نجاحه في مسك العصا
من الوسط مع قيادات تحالف اداره الدوله
حتى الساعه على الرغم من وجود الخلافات
التي لا يحسب لها وزن في الحكومات
الائتلافيه الخلاف النفطي والمالي بين
اربيل وبغداد تم حله ولو بشكل مؤقت نامل
الان ليس فقط على حل المشاكل وانما على
البدء من جديد بتطبيق واقع شراكه حقيقيه
هدفه بناء العراق بكل مناطقه من زاخو الى
الفاو وتقدم بخطوات واعتقد هذا شيء ايجابي
جدا ومساله الاتفاق النفط الاخير كان واضح
لحل اغلب المشاكل النفطيه بين بغداد
واربيل لحين تشريع قانون النفط والغاز
اعاده النازحين الى مناطقهم في جرف الصخر
وغيرها من بين الملفات التي تعهد السودان
بحلها امام القوى السنيه يضاف اليها تمرير
قانون العفو العام في البرلمان لم يتمكن
السوداني من تنفيذها الى الان الرئيس
الوزراء هو يكاد يكون ملزم بالاتفاق الذي
وقع ما بين الكتل السياسيه فيما يخص
موضوعات العفو العام بالنسبه
للاتفاق الذي جرى بين القوى السياسيه قبل
تشكيل الحكومه
اما شعبيا فكانت علاماته رضا والامل باديه
على وجوه العراقيين الذين ينتظرون المزيد
من حكومه السودان اقتصاديا خلوه يشتغل
بخير تيجي على الخدمات الخدمات افضل يعني
اكو تحسن زين بالعمل هذا موجود وملموس
يعني بالنسبه للشارع العراقي حكومه
السوداني تريد تختصر المسافه الزمنيه اللي
صاله عشرين سنه بدون خدمات الى خدمات
سريعه جدا هذا نحسه بس يريد نلمسه بعد عن
طريق الواقع وين يحتاج لواقت
تقديم الخدمات وضبط سعر صرف الدولار نسبيا
واستمرار الانفتاح على المحيط العربي
والدولي عوامل ايجابيه لنجاح حكومه
السودان لكن الاختبار الحقيقي لها يتمثل
بالتعديل الوزاري المرتقب والذي سيشمل
ثلاثه حقائب لم يتم الكشف عن اسمائها بعد
من بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات